bonjour marc fesneau mongeau ministre de
l'agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire on va parler de l'avenir des
agriculteurs des intempéries saisonnière
d'abord le pouvoir d'achat des français
puisque c'est d'actualité ça concerne
aussi les les produits frais en grande
surface d'ailleurs à qui la faute
d'ailleurs l'augmentation des prix des
produits agricoles dans les grandes
surfaces l'augmentation des prix
agricoles il est le produit de la crise
en ukraine qui par un effet de
contamination démarrant sur la question
énergétique fécamp chaîne parce que pour
produire dans un certain nombre de cas
il faut de l'énergie qui pour fabriquer
des engrais qui pour transformer qui
pour faire du transport qui pour
emballer et et donc l'augmentation des
prix elle est liée à ça et donc c'est ça
qui est un élément évidemment
d'inquiétude c'est pas une inflation à
vrai dire d'emballement du moteur
économique c'est une inflation importée
du fait de la crise du crédit n ayant
peur importés principalement par la
hausse du coût des carburants et du des
coûts de l'énergie pas que les
carburants évidemment le gaz donc c'est
ça qui est bien un sujet évidemment de
préoccupation la l'ukraine a peut-être
bon dos mais ce que les distributeurs de
faire des efforts pour l'heure mais
c'est pas la question de savoir si
l'ukraine a bon dos et la question de
savoir vous avez raison de poser la
question en ces termes c'est chacun doit
prendre sa part de l'effort à faire je
rappelle que dans les doigts égalise 1-1
et galim deux qui ont été votées par le
parlement la dernière et galim de était
à l'automne de migrateurs lille et le 6
est ce que ce que c'était des lois qui
visait à faire en sorte qu'on retrouve
de la valeur sur l'ensemble de la chaîne
que des gaz agriculteurs soient mieux il
est en particulier que les agriculteurs
soient mieux rémunérés parce qu'on
voyait bien que la valeur se concentrer
la marge se concentrer sur la grande
distribution c'est pour ça qu'on a fait
des textes parce que manifestement les
choses ne faisait pas naturellement il
est normal que la loi puisse intervenir
ça dit edwards michel edouard leclerc
dit que c'est ce dispositif et galim ça
limite la capacité dit-il à baisser les
prix de chez les jets des districts et
clc la vieille théorie de michel edouard
leclerc qui tourne sur tous les sujets
si vous remontez 40 ans en arrière il
était contre le prix unique du livre
parce qu'il estimait qu'il pouvait faire
des prix plus placé quand même comme ça
qu'on a sauvé l'économie du livre et
l'économie des libraires donc ça mais
c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça
pardonnez moi dans la loi et gally monde
y voit là les remise promotionnelle
ses 34 % maximum sur le prix de vente du
producteur bruno le maire cette semaine
a dit bon on pourrait peut-être aller
jusqu'à 50% c'est ce que demande
effectivement
les grandes surfaces les patrons des
grandes et grands supermarchés
rétropédalage du gouvernement mais on a
le sentiment quand même que c'est pas
encore très sûr vous pensez quoi vous
répondez sans mais c'est pas plus
compliqué je répondais simplement à la
question de ce qui en permanence dès
qu'on essaie de réguler le commerce
quand il est dérivé c'est ça donc c'est
quand même c'est quand même bien de le
rappeler la deuxième chose c'est
qu'effectivement se pose la question de
savoir où est ce qu est la marge et où
est ce qu est la marche qui reste il est
légitime compose des débats sur ces
questions-là la loi et galim les lois
galy mais vise à faire quoi qu'on parte
on construise le prix à partir du coup
producteurs et qu'on construise pas le
prix à partir du prix distributeurs qui
après en descente venez faire pression
d'où la limitation par exemple des
éléments promotionnels d'où le fait
qu'on ne paye puisse pas vendre à moins
que le seuil de revente à perte plus 10%
pourquoi parce qu'on sait bien qu'il y
avait ce qu'on appelait les marges
arrière et qui faisait que en acheter à
100 puis en fait en temps réel en
acheter à 90 en tout cas en réel le
producteur était payée à 90 donc c'est
ça la volonté est là et l'intuition qui
est la nôtre après ce qu'a posée bruno
le maire à juste titre sur le débat
c'est est ce que ça fonctionne bien
c'est pour ça qu'ils aient une mission
d'inspection qui a été fait parce qu'on
voit bien qu'il ya un certain nombre de
cas où le mécanisme qui permettrait y
compris de faire de la promotion ne se
met pas en oeuvre ont donc 17 heures à
venir peut-être sur la loi et
galimzyanov j'ai pas dit qu'on allait
revenir sur la loi galy on va regarder
d'abord si ça fonctionne sur les
promotions aujourd'hui on peut aller
jusqu'à 34% hors ce qu'on constate dans
la plupart des cas c'est que la grande
distribution n'est qu'à 21 donc ils ont
des marges donc ils ont la capacité à
faire en sorte que même il porte une
partie de l'effort parce qu'une partie
de l'effort aussi qui est porté par
l'état je veux dire les mesures pouvoir
d'achat dont on parlera peut-être tout à
l'heure y compris sur l'alimentation
c'est l'état et donc c'est des impôts
des français qui les payent et donc il
faut que chacun prenne sa part mais ça
peut pas être au prix de revenir sur 10
enfin des dizaines d'années ou à la fin
c'était toujours le producteur et
l'agriculteur qui lui ne trouvait pas sa
marge alors cette semaine le
gouvernement a lancé le cheikh
alimentaire une centaine d'euros + 50
euros par enfant pour les familles les
plus pauvres la fnsea principal syndicat
agricole préférerait un dispositif plus
pérenne qui ciblerait les les produits
locaux d'abord voient leurs réponses et
bien la pensée que nous avons en mai
vous me rendais bien compte que de
mettre en place un shack alimentaire
sait quels moyens de distribution est ce
que c'est un chef type chèques
restaurant donc quel lieu ça se diffuse
quand vous voulez agir rapidement il
faut d'abord faire un dispositif qui
soit simple et rapide donc première
étape c'est l'étape qui posait dans le
projet de loi de finances rectificatif
qui permet 100 euros + 50 euros par
enfant vous l'avez dit effectivement aux
français les plus modestes
d'accéder ses 11 millions de foyers à
peu près qui vont être concernés qui par
leur permet d'accéder à l'alimentation
et de ne pas dégrader trop leur pouvoir
d'achat et puis dans un deuxième temps
il y aura besoin de travailler mais là
c'est sur le projet de loi de finances
2010 23 sur un dispositif qui est plus
pérenne d'ailleurs la première ministre
a annoncé y compris dans son discours de
politique générale là on est dans une
mesure d'urgence et toutes les mesures
que nous avons sur la table plfr sont
des mesures d'urgence le chèque
alimentaire je vous rappelle que c'est
le produit de la convention citoyenne
sur le climat j'allais dire c'est
inscrit dans la loi c'est normalement ce
sera devrait déjà être appliquées
sauf que ça paraît simple de dire on
fait un chèque alimentaire et c'est
compliqué à mettre en place et c'est à
la fois parfois techniquement compliqué
comme on fait on fait des remises de
caisse ont fait un chèque fin bref et
puis 2 sait quels types de produits
produits transformés produits non
transformés produits frais prises et
l'aimer sincèrement ce but kelly québec
il a encore une fois la grande
distribution n'ont pas lu tous annoncés
c'est un sujet un débat complexe avec
tout le monde parce que certains disent
il faut mettre tous les produits
transformés compris tel ou tel élément
qui sont plutôt des produits non pas de
consommation de base mais des produits
plus divers d'autres disent il faut s
qu'on inscrit on a introduit la question
de qualité du produit donc on va se
mettre au travail avec l'ensemble des
écosystèmes pour regarder ce qui est le
mieux calibrée avec une volonté première
c'est la volonté que ça touche les plus
fragiles d'entre nous et qu'ils puissent
accéder à une alimentation de qualité
donc vous dites ils existeront c'est
chaque alimentaire et s'était affirmée
aux églises existeront dans le à partir
de 2023 la volonté que nous avons c'est
de faire en sorte que ça soit déployée
dans sa version 2 si je peux dire mais
dans la première version il fallait agir
dans l'urgence on est le 15 juillet
quasiment faut que ça soit mis en oeuvre
pour le 1er septembre vous comprenez
bien que pour qu'on ait un dispositif
qui marche parce que l'important c'est
que ça marche il fallait d'abord dans un
premier temps faire cela elisabeth
borgne a promis une loi d'orientation
agricole que vous allez
menés marc fesneau notamment pour une
meilleure rémunération des agriculteurs
quels seront vos levier pour mieux payer
les agriculteurs alors effectivement
c'est d'ailleurs elle prolonge et en
cela il ya un engagement du président de
la république je crois que ça avait été
pris au salon de l'agriculture la
volonté c'est d'agir sur tous les
leviers qui permettent de tracer un
avenir et des perspectives c'est bien
une loi d'orientation dont il s'agit
alors ça traite de questions
d'installation et de sessions
d'exploitation parce que dans les dix
ans qui viennent 60 % des agriculteurs
on pourra partir à la retraite c'est
plus de 200 mille agriculteurs et il a
combien qui rentre sur en moyenne ces
dizaines de milliers votre angle
souviennent d'une quinzaine de milliards
l'installation puis à la rémunération la
question à ma nation mais le sujet de
souveraineté est un sujet global si je
peux me permettre parce que le sujet
mais ça commence et vous avez raison par
le sujet de la rémunération le sujet de
la rémunération c'est ce qu'on vient de
dire sur la capacité à faire en sorte
que dans la chaîne de valeur alimentaire
les agriculteurs le prix se construisent
à partir du coût des agriculteurs le
deuxième élément c'est qu'on puisse
organiser un certain nombre de filières
qu'on peut être besoin de organisé mieux
le marché par rapport à la demande de
consommateurs avec des investissements
qui sont parfois lourd en terme de
modification de pratiques ou de
modification de produits la rémunération
c'est aussi la capacité à moderniser nos
industries agroalimentaires dans un
contexte supplémentaire qui est un
contexte de décarbonation il faut
comporte tout ça ça va porter sur les
questions de rémunération et puis c'est
sans doute que nous ayons les uns et les
autres
comme consommateur comme citoyen et
comme consommateur une réflexion sur
pour avoir d'une agriculture en france
de privilégier des produits de qualité
nous avons une des filières et une
agriculture qui est de qualité quand on
se compare à des besoins de partir très
loin de nos frontières et donc l'acte
consommateurs et est un acte important
je me souviens vous souvenez peut-être
une campagne à m'inquiéter nos emplettes
sont nos emplois et à la vérité nos
emplettes c'est aussi l'orientation de
notre agriculture parce que derrière le
produit
derrière le consommateur est un citoyen
est derrière le produit peut toujours
penser qu'un agriculteur alors la
rémunération c'est fait l'installation
favoriser l'installation comment
souhaitez-vous
susciter des vocations à la manière
formation et la première nécessité dans
un an pour le man 2 le monde agricole a
vécu pendant la période de pâques
jusqu'à 4 jusqu'au début des années 2000
sur une forme de stabilisation est au
fond un modèle économique dont on savait
où il était or les dérèglements économie
les dérèglements climatiques font que
quand vous installez et que vous
empruntez pour vous installez vous
n'avez pas une visibilité économique
satisfaisante donc c'est pour ça que la
rémunération est un premier élément
deuxième élément avec le nombre
d'agriculteurs que nous avons une grande
partie des installations vont se faire
hors du cadre familial commander c'est à
dire que vous avez beaucoup de jeunes
qui ne seront pas en première génération
issue de parents agriculteurs donc on a
travaillé sur un modèle qui permette de
mieux attirer ces jeunes là évidemment
les jeunes fils d'agriculteur troisième
sujet il ya parfois des outils si vous
permettait qui sont très performants
mais qui sont difficiles à reprendre
parce qu'il ya des capitaux qui sont
compliqués quatrième sujet il ya parfois
l'accès au foncier en particulier dans
les zones périurbaines où il ya de la
conflictuelle it et d'usagers qui fait
que vous voulez vous installer mais il
ya un projet économique et un projet de
lotissement et qu'au fond si vous
achetez au prix du lotissement vous
n'avez pas de rentabilité économique
donc c'est sur tous ces sujets là qu'il
va falloir travailler j'ajoute
évidemment l'outil formation on a un
enseignement agricole qui est formidable
qui est très spécifique à la france et
qui doit nous permettre d'accompagner à
la fois sur le métier de production mais
aussi sur les grandes transitions qui
sont à l'heure ces jeunes nombreux dit
vous qui veulent rentrer dans ce métier
sans avoir des ascendants dans le milieu
quel genre d'agriculture les attire ils
vont entrer dans la vie que c'est assez
c'est assez variable vous avez est ce
que c'est le bio qui a la cote une
quote-part tard hier vous avez des
jeunes qui veulent s'installer en
maraîchage encore qu'il faille faut-il
dès lors on est plutôt sur des systèmes
en surface qui sont petits encore
fait-il qu'on puisse leur proposer un
modèle économique et face qu'au bout de
trois ans ne sorte pas donc une question
d'accompagnement puis d'autres sur des
filières plus
plus traditionnelle plus sa
traditionnelle j'ai pas le maraîchage et
traditionnelles aussi mon fond des
filières plus grandes cultures ou
polyculture élevage l'élevage et crème
très astreignant il faut quand même
penser à chaque fois aux éleveurs parce
qu'en laitiers ou en bovins viande ou
dans d'autres secteurs c'est un travail
de tous les jours je pense que c'est
surtout les secteurs qu'il faut essayer
devrait alors en tout cas le bio est peu
soutenue par la france 3 % seulement des
aides de la pac reviennent aux
exploitants bio alors que 80 % des
agriculteurs perçoivent des déversements
de la politique agricole commune l'union
européenne nous a même demandé de
rectifier le tir de rectifier la
répartition de ces aides pour en donner
un peu plus au bio ça fait cinq ans
qu'ils émanent de macron est au pouvoir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pendant cinq
ans avec la filière bio mais ce qui
s'est passé pendant cinq ans ou six ans
avec la filière bio c'est que nous
sommes 13 % d'exploitants agricoles qui
sont en bio et que nous avons quasiment
doubler les surfaces voilà ce qui s'est
passé parce que l'important c'est le
concret mais vous les allées audi peut
accompagner ils ont été accompagnés
manifestement ils ont été accompagnés
puisqu'il ya un certain nombre
d'installations on avait culture bio
j'ajoute souvent que c'est un cetain
c'est souvent un chemin pour arriver à
l'agriculture biologique par ton parfois
certains commencent à rentrer dans des
dispositifs de haute valeur
environnementale par exemple et après
ils se mettent ils se mettent en route
pour aller vers la bio pour ce qu'ils
veulent les circuits courts sont un
formidable levier pour parce que vous
êtes en dialogue avec les citoyens et
les consommateurs et donc c'est souvent
un moment d'interrogation et donc sur le
bio on a avancé puisque comme les
chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes et puis un
troisième chauffer les chiffres par deux
maîtres d'eux-mêmes en termes
d'européennes qui nous dit il ya un
problème 3% seulement des versements
l'europe elle ne disait pas ça elle
disait qu'il fallait différencier le bio
pour avoir suivi ce dossier depuis que
je suis arrivé elle disait il faut mieux
différencier le bio des autres
certifications environnementales
en gros c'est qu'ici on reproche à la
france d'utiliser encore trop de de
pesticides en france je vous pose la
question votre gouvernement
envisage-t-il d'autoriser à nouveau une
prochaine campagne d'utilisation des
controversés nicotine oïda ce pesticides
tueurs d'abeilles pour les betteraves
sucrières comme ça a été le cas durant
quatre mois en février dernier est ce
qu'on ne permettait de dire qu'il
faudrait arrêter de dire que la
commission reproche à la france la
commission un lignes directrices qu'est
la réduction des pesticides et la france
est plutôt mieux' meilleurs élèves que
d'autres sur ces sujets là leur deuxième
élément je vais vous répondre deuxième
élément on est sur une tendance de
diminution ce ne serait ce que sur le
glyphosate en quatre ans on a baissé de
moitié l'utilisation du glyphosate pour
les pots de lait produits qui étaient
les plus classes et on est ce qu'on
appelle les cmr 1 on a réduit de 93%
donc aide il ya des actes et des faits
puis troisième chose sur les
néonicotinoïdes ce que j'aime bien
répondent aux questions précises qui
vous sont posées on a décidé d'une
dérogation parce que nous étions dans
une impasse technique on a donné trois
ans en mettant 20 millions d'euros
d'euros 2 me de mémoire sur la recherche
pour essayer de trouver des alternatives
techniques des alternatives de
biocontrôle ce qu'on appelle du contrôle
au niveau européen en plus lent au
niveau national c'est le parce que ça
n'est pas interdit au niveau européen
les néonicotinoïdes pardon donc c'est
c'est la france qui est plutôt en avant
mais ça ne marche que si on n'est pas
les gens dans des situations d'impasse
parce que c'est cette volonté de dire on
interdit on laisse les agriculteurs
français sans solution et aux frontières
immédiate en belgique en allemagne on
continue à faire de la betterave avec
des néonicotinoïdes ça ça peut pas
marcher donc on est en train de nous
dire qu'on ne se passera pas une
nouvelle fois d'une nouvelle campagne je
dois dire que non on a trois ans de
dérogation donc jusqu'à la campagne 2023
j'ai demandé très vite dès que je suis
arrivé de savoir où on en était sûrs les
recherches via des itinéraires
techniques des expérimentations qui sont
menées depuis depuis deux ans on aura
une troisième année d'expérimentation et
j'ai bon espoir et quand je dis j'ai bon
espoir en tandem en bien j'ai bon espoir
que nous puissions à sortir parce que
c'est la volonté à la fois les
agriculteurs et notre lente donc on va
réussir à se hisser au haut niveau à la
hauteur des enjeux de la transition
écologique oui mais c'est toujours une
difficulté voyez bien que la transition
le problème c'est de la transition c'est
de la capacité non pas il n'y a pas de
mauvaise volonté il faut arrêter de dire
que les agriculteurs n'ont pas de bonne
volonté ils ont beaucoup peuvent
réception sans doute que ce campus
devrait mêler marche ont parfois
tellement hot qu'il faut essayer de se
mettre sur un chemin et c'est à ça que
sert la planification s'est déroulé le
point voilà le point b et comment
j'arrive du point a au point b parce que
sinon dire simplement c'est le point b
je ne donne pas de solution est donc
c'est la recherche c'est l'innovation
c'est le matériel enfin c'est des tas de
sujets sur lesquels ont donc on les
marges sont très difficiles et très
haute mais je trouve qu'on est plutôt
bien engagée mais il faut sans doute
qu'on accélère mais ça n'est pas valable
que dans le domaine agricole on voit
bien à propos des intempéries maintenant
vous l'avais dit à l'agriculture subite
point fut de plein fouet les le
changement climatique de plus en plus
dévastateurs est ce que les agriculteurs
vont pouvoir compter dès janvier 2023 de
la nouvelle loi sur l'assurance récolte
c'est bien l'objectif je le rappelle
c'est une loi qui a été promulguée en
mars 2022 donc c'est très court comme
délai donc on a besoin d'aller très vite
et de mettre un peu de pression dans le
tube si vous me permettez cette
expression pour faire en sorte que nous
soyons au rendez vous du premier du 1er
janvier 2023 pourquoi parce que le
système assurantiel beaucoup
d'agriculteurs n'y ont pas recours
l'arboriculture c'est 2 à 3 %
d'agriculteurs qui sont couverts un
système élevage prairie c'est peu de
monde et donc le système assurantiel qui
vise à ce qu'une contribution de l'état
qui double en moyenne sur la période qui
va s'ouvrir ça doit permettre
par un mécanisme volontaire mais un
mécanisme de subventionnement aux
agriculteurs de mieux accéder à
l'assurance pour être mieux couverts
parce que la vérité la normalité devient
la norme et encore du les mauvaises
années il ya encore des discussions oui
à ces discussions
le seuil à partir duquel sera déclenché
la solidarité nation c'était la seule il
ya des discussions avec les assureurs
sur la manière dont ça s'organise les
discussions avec l'ensemble des filières
pour savoir où ça se déclenche quelle
est la part de solidarité nationale
quelle est la part assurantiel qui est
en pleine discussion c'est bien travail
que nous avons à faire mais la face à la
sécheresse on a eu un printemps déjà
très très chaud on a eu un été
particulièrement sec en tout cas pour
l'instant il ya déjà des fonds dead sa
sélection qui existent aujourd'hui c'est
les fonds de calamité agricole et après
je reviendrai peut-être sur la grêle
face et c'est pas tout à fait de même
nature à chaque fois le gouvernement a
été au rendez vous on l'a fait sur le
gel donc on est en train j'ai lancé une
mission d'inspection le d'évaluation il
ya trois semaines dont j'aurai les
résultats nous courant de la semaine
prochaine qui nous permettra de mieux de
calibrer au mieux les outils on a eu des
événements qui ont été très nombreux
très puissant et souvent très localisées
donc faut qu'on arrive à adapter une
réponse qui soit une réponse pour
combiner la le concret de la réponse et
la rapidité de la réponse mais justement
pour être précis après la séquence de
grêle il ya quelques jours les
agriculteurs ont demandé une meilleure
réactivité de la prise en charge c'est
sur les rails ça est sur les rails mais
reconnaissons qu'il faut il faut
respecter il faut pouvoir contrôler les
chacune des parcelles s'est fait
d'ailleurs avec les services de l'état
comment je tiens à saluer la
mobilisation les gens de la culture qui
travaille beaucoup avec nous pour faire
en sorte précisément que les choses
soient faites alors vous connaissez bien
le parlement aussi vous êtes l'ancien
ministre des relations avec le parlement
est ce qu'elle vous inquiète cette
majorité présidentielle relative
désormais à l'assemblée est ce que la
culture du compromis ça s'apprend et on
va réussir à apprendre la culture du
compromis ça s'apprend et la culture du
compromis ça doit s'apprendre pour tous
on devrait déjà le savoir où ça
s'apprend effectivement nous sommes sans
doute le seul pays qui voient les choses
en noir au blanc pour ou contre alors
que tous les pays qui nous environne y
compris au delà de nos frontières
atlantique si je peux dire savent ce que
c'est que le compromis parlementaires et
les majorité relative et vous répondez
pas ma question vont s'en va faire ou
pas ben moi je pense qu'on saura faire
dès lors que la majorité sera ouverte ce
qu'a dit d'ailleurs la première ministre
pour faire en sorte qu'on essaie de
trouver des compromis et que à côté de
nous en face de nous sur les bancs des
hémicycles des gens disent je suis prêt
à faire un compromis j'ai entendu des
déclarations pour dire on n'est pas venu
pour faire un compromis mais là si on
regarde le premier texte par exemple le
pouvoir d'achat
c'est le gouvernement qui a présenté son
taxi d'un travail en amont pour essayer
trait sur un texte budgétaire s'est pas
illogique que le gouvernement présente
son texte et que apprend puisse en
discuter en commission et après au
parlement mais il ya le texte budgétaire
moi je veux dire j'ai un exemple très
concret je suis je suis conseiller
régional d'opposition au président
françois bonneau je fais pas la course à
l'échalote de la dépense et la démagogie
de la dépense j'essaie de trouver avec
lui des terrains d'entente et lui il
fait la même chose avec moi on a essayé
de faire en sorte d'avoir un chu orléans
ne pas lier complètement mais qu'est ce
qu'on a fait on a travaillé ensemble on
n'a pas cherché à piéger l'autre et à
faire en sorte que l'autre se plante
pardonnez moi l'expression donc ça
marche le compromis au niveau local les
secours si ça se passe bien de repos si
ça marche bien aussi en europe où vous
parlement européen c'est à dire qu'on
essaie de trouver des compromis mais si
le compromis c'est d'essayer de faire
trébucher l'autre en se disant dans
l'élection suivante je lui ferai la fête
alors à ce moment là c'est pas un
compromis et c'est tout à gries cole
c'est prévu pour quand les deux horizons
2023 c'est parce qu'il ya besoin de
beaucoup de concertation puisque vous
avez vu il ya beaucoup de sujets merci
beaucoup marc fesneau ni au ministre de
l'agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci d'être venu nous en
parlait ce matin sur france inter il est
20h40